spider-man far from home has dropped a
very big and obvious Doctor Strange to
Easter Egg how's it going everyone it's
Warren and don't worry there will be no
spoilers for spider-man fire from home
in this video as everything that we are
going to be talking about has already
been shown in some of the trailers but
this Doctor Strange Easter egg and
Spider Man fire from home could have a
lot bigger meaning in a lot more
importance than what the movie actually
makes it out to have so we're gonna talk
about the Doctor Strange to Easter Egg
and spider-man far from home and what it
means about Doctor Strange - and the
plot for it but quick reminder if you
would like a chance to win a Captain
America shield an Iron Man helmet and
Infinity Gauntlet or another Marvel
Legends item be sure to subscribe to my
channel I'm doing a giveaway and picking
three winners at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers so again this is
all in some of the trailers and clips
that were shown but when spider-man is
getting roped into having to fight the
elementals he thinks that it's a little
above his pay grade and a little above
his head so he starts naming other
heroes that could possibly take care of
the threat now of course our sweet Tony
is no longer with us so spider-man asked
about Thor and fury says that he's
offworld then he asked about Captain
Marvel and he says don't invoke that
name and then he asks about Doctor
Strange and then Maria Hill chimes in
very mysteriously and says that he is
unavailable I need an Avenger off-world
Doctor Strange unavailable Captain
Marvel don't invoke your name now there
are two possible explanations for why
Doctor Strange is unavailable one is
that him being the master of the mystic
arts he knows that the elementals are
fake and don't really have a real threat
on the earth this is a definite
possibility and Doctor Strange has been
known to sit out of fights such as civil
war in the comics however a more likely
explanation is that he is dealing with
matters of his own specifically matters
and problems that will be revealed in
Doctor Strange - at the end of Doctor
Strange Mordo made a jump over to the
dark side claiming that there are too
many sorcerers setting him up to be the
villain of Doctor Strange - so he could
be dealing with more dough during this
time but another big thing to note is
that Doctor Strange no longer has the
eye of agamotto and the time stone this
is something that single-handedly
prevented Dormammu from a
hacking and destroying earth this is
something that the ancient one also
mentioned was very crucial for defending
earth against very dark forces and
Avengers end game and now Doctor Strange
no longer has it so the earth is
technically open to a lot of different
attacks right now and not to mention
that it is speculated that name work
could be a villain and Doctor Strange
too as well scott derrickson the
director of Doctor Strange and Doctor
Strange - posted an image on Instagram
that had Namor in it implying that he
was going to be the next villain in
Avengers and gay McCoy he mentions an
underwater earthquake and although the
researchers came out and said that this
was not a name or easter egg they also
said that Avengers in game wasn't going
to be the title so they could have just
said that to avoid any possible spoilers
for Doctor Strange - so Doctor Strange
being unavailable to help fight the
elementals and Spider Man fire from home
could mean that he simply knew that they
were fake and that they did not actually
need his help but it most likely means
that he is dealing with a problem of his
own most likely a very dark and powerful
force especially since this takes place
not too long after all of the events of
Avengers and Gaiman the earth is very
vulnerable but be sure to let me know
what you think in the comments down
below do you think Doctor Strange will
be fighting some dark force during this
time when spider-man far from home takes
place or do you think that he simply
knew that the elementals were fake let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below and of course be sure to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof